You're always contrasting what you want
and happy with what you think is that
they're both more and wherever there's a
deviation,
wherever what you want to happen isn't
going on.
Then you feel anxiety,
curiosity as well here in pell to
explore the anxiety is the thing that
comes up first and the larger the
magnitude of the unexpected occurrence,
the greater the amount of anxiety.
One of the things we're going to try to
determine in the courses,
how you can understand how large a
disruption and given unexpected event is
because you know,
minor thing.
Let's go back to this other diner for a
second.
Here's a.
here's a way of looking at it.
So let's say you're,
you know,
you're going to wear three plans to get
there and this plan doesn't work,
so that means that produces outcomes.
It isn't what you envisioned and this
plan doesn't work.
It produces on a normal civilian as
well.
But this plan does work well.
That's no problem.
I mean those are pretty minor league
disruptions.
All you do is you keep the same vision
of yourself and the same vision of the
future.
You just switched between plants and
you're really in trouble if none of your
plans work or if someone messes around
with your representation of this for
this,
so you can say,
for example,
you want to get into medical school and
you need 30 courses to get into medical
school and you should have a's on all of
them and you get a b plus on one course.
Okay,
well,
he's done all these other courses.
That's not such a big deal.
It's a minor league disruption.
It causes you a certain mode of anxiety
and produces a certain amount of
exploratory behavior.
Perhaps go with the professor and say,
why isn't that I got this being the last
one is expecting a don't.
You don't what that's going to do the
vision of the ideal future and so on and
so forth.
That's one sort of disruption.
You're a bit anxious,
but hey,
you have 29 other courses.
It's not such a big deal.
Now instead,
write down cap and You score in the 50th
percentile.
Well now you're in trouble because you
have a vision of yourself.
We think this is your version of the
unbearable present.
You know a doctor that's a pain in the
neck,
but you're a potential doctor.
You have the intellectual resources at
your disposal and the educational
background and and and the familial push
perhaps to make him into a doctor,
and so that's what you perceived
yourself as.
That's your story about yourself because
you're the person with this set number
of potentials and you also have a visual
of what it is that you're going,
oh,
am score comes back and you're in the
15th percentile.
Well,
your,
your ideal future is gone.
That's a big problem because that means
that all of the events that have
surrounded you,
that surround you now and as far back as
you can remember,
that were given determinant significance
by this particular plan have all been
cast into chaos because everything that
you've done up to that point has been
predicated on the notion that this is
where you were going and that means that
the significance that you attributed to
me,
everything was attributed to everything
in relationship to that goal.
You blow out the goal and all those
significant,
sir,
back up in the air,
you have to modify your version of
yourself like what the hell are you
going to do now they're going to be a
doctor.
He put a lot of work into this.
Plus it's your whole self conception.
Well this is gone.
This is gone.
This is irrelevant,
right?
I mean the other 29 courses,
why the hell are you even here now?
So that's one example of the levels at
which normally occur.
Minor League anomalies,
no problem.
You just screwed around with when you go
to the same place,
major league anomalies,
it's a new ideal future.
That's part of the reason that people
are so prone to ideological conflicts.
It's like this is an ideology can say it
has a particular version of the way
things are.
Knowing a little bit for me to see
college is pretty.
It's pretty explicit.
What's the unbearable presence so to
speak?
Well,
I know this is a bit dated,
but we're running out of hard line
etiologies to fund that,
but by the time the unbearable present
is the class struggle and we kind of
reasons for that,
it's basically the fault of the are
exploring before the ideal future is the
point at which those unfair divisions of
capital are eliminated debt.
There's a whole bunch of means to that
end.
That's that's an ideology.
While someone else has a different
ideology,
different version of the significance of
current events,
a different version of the significance
and the nature of the ideal future,
how they completely different
apprehension of how to transform one and
the other.
With those two cultures come into
contact with how,
first of all,
they make each other anxious because
they're not convinced,
commensurate pools,
and if this is the structure that
regulates emotion,
well what's going to happen?
You can just give up your damn plans
because then your emotions are
dysregulated.
We fall into chaos so to speak.
You don't know where you are and you
don't know who you are.
You don't know what to do and you don't
know where you're going because that
makes you anxious.
Neither side is going to give up.
Give up near certainty.
The only thing left and under what
circumstances is conflict and you see
this look,
how do arguments escalate?
An argument with someone that you love
even they want one thing.
You want another,
you discuss it.
You know,
getting anywhere your tempers raised
because the abstract discussion isn't
healthy.
Finally,
you give up,
maybe move to to violence to solve your
problem,
to hammer out story,
so to speak and do that,
but still oppressing the person who has
the different different.